l'hypnose l'hypnose médicale même bon la
première chose à laquelle vous pensez
c'est sûrement l'hypnothérapie
psychologique ah mais oui c'est
exactement ça que je pensais comment tu
le sais tu m'as hypnotisé ça pénétré non
rien de magique là-dedans personne ne va
pénétrer votre esprit ou quoi que ce
soit d'autre mais elle est aussi
utilisée par des médecins y compris à
l'hôpital il y a deux utilisations
principales l'hypnose analgésie là le
but de l'hypnose ça va être de diminuer
la douleur la deuxième utilisation de
l'hypnose médicale c'est ce qu'on
appelle l'hypnose sédation c'est dater
ça veut dire apaiser calmer ça consiste
à abaisser un petit peu le niveau de
vigilance de conscience si vous voulez
ça peut être juste pour calmer quelqu'un
qui est très agité par exemple ou qui
est très stressé parce qu'on va lui
faire et ça peut aller jusqu'à
l'anesthésie y compris l'anesthésie
générale et on a remarqué que ça
permettait de diminuer les doses de
médicaments nécessaires voire parfois de
les remplacer complètement alors
attention ça remplace pas l'anesthésie
générale ça peut permettre de garder
quelqu'un conscient mais de mettre la
personne dans les meilleures conditions
pour supporter l'opération